ta parole est un monsieur pierre
lellouche merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur à l'occasion de votre
audition il ya deux jours devant la
commission d' enquête sur le terrorisme
vous nous avez informé que lors des
attentats de paris le 13 novembre pas
moins de 125 véhicules de police et de
secours avaient dû être mobilisé en
urgence pour les attentats on vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que madame la
maire de paris a décidé effet voté
d'ailleurs sans la moindre concertation
ni avec les parisiens ni avec les élus
parisiens et franciliens qu'à compter de
l'été prochain
la voie express georges pompidou sera
définitivement fermé la circulation la
totalité du trafic d'ouest en est le
long de la seine va donc passer sur les
quais hauts entre la concorde et la
bastille qui sont déjà comme vous le
savez totalement embouteillée situation
aggravée par les travaux de la
samaritaine et du centre de paris idéal
la question que je vous pose le nom de
tous mes collègues de philippe goujon de
nathalie kosciusko morizet de mes
collègues du conseil de paris des
républicains concerne la sécurité de la
capitale
dans une période où nous savons que
malheureusement d'autres actes
terroristes vont se produire
comment allez vous gérer l'intervention
des forces de l'ordre et les secours
surtout s'il ya plusieurs attentats dans
des quais qui sont totalement bouchées
d'ores et déjà la sécurité de la
capitale monsieur mise intérieur et
votre responsabilité vous avez la
tutelle directe sur le préfet de police
qui par ailleurs a la responsabilité
pénale personnel en cas d'erreur dans la
préparation des des systèmes de sécurité
et de secours à paris ma question est
donc simple allez vous autorisez la
maire de paris à imposer son projet dès
cet été
quoi qu'il arrive ou bien êtes vous
prêts
comme vous le suggère l'opposition à
envisager un moratoire qui permettra
d'étudier les formules alternatives et
de s'assurer que cette dimension vital
de la sécurité des parisiens est
désormais inclus dans les plans de
circulation de la ville
merci monsieur lellouche la parole est
un monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur bernard cazeneuve
je comprends monsieur le député
lellouche que les débats au sein du
conseil de paris sont tellement
passionnant que vous voulez nous en
faire partager le plaisir et je vous en
remercie d'ailleurs parce que la
question ne manque pas d'intérêt et elle
relève pour partie de ma compétence
ce qui justifie que vous me la dre scié
et je vais y répondre bien volontiers et
puisque vous faisait référence aux
informations que j'ai données devant la
mission de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire il ya de ça quelques jours
je ne peux pas imaginer une minute que
vous ne vous souveniez pas de m'avoir
déjà posé la question et par conséquent
d'avoir déjà la réponse mais ce n'est
pas grave
la pédagogie était un étang anar de la
répétition je vais volontiers répondre à
la question que vous me posez dans les
mêmes termes que ceux que je vous
indiquais la dernière fois parce que
sinon vous pourriez me reprocher d'avoir
un discours à géométrie variable
premier point nous avons arrêté un
dispositif avec la maire de paris qui
est d'assez simple qui est tout à fait
conforme aux responsabilités que vous
avez indiquée lorsque des aménagements
sont prévus
outre les études d'impact qui doivent
avoir lieu nous prenons en compte ces
aménagements la préfecture de police de
paris pour regarder quel est l'impact de
ces aménagements sur les questions de
sécurité que vous venez d'évoquer je
crois d'ailleurs que le préfet de police
a dû vous recevoir vendredi à moins
qu'il ne vous reçoit vendredi prochain
pour vous confirmer en tout point à ce
que je viens de vous dire par conséquent
les projets de madame la maire de paris
seront regardées avec beaucoup
d'attention par la préfecture de police
s'il y a dans ses aménagements des
éléments qui contrarient l'intervention
des secours
nous demanderons à la maire de paris de
bien vouloir procéder à la modification
de son projet mais bien entendu ce que
nous faisons avec la ville de paris vise
à faire en sorte que ces projets
environnementaux puisse aboutir dans le
respect des principes de sécurité nous
ne sommes pas là pour entraver ses
projets mais pour les rendent possibles
dans le respect des prérogatives qui
sont les nôtres et je rendrai compte à
la représentation nationale et à tous
les députés de paris de l'opposition qui
sont mobilisés sur une grande cause des
décisions que j'aurais été amené à
prendre sur la base du rapport du préfet
de police
la séance des questions au gouvernement
et terminer la séance est suspendue